Musique pesante
-C'est un droit des femmes,
il est autorisé depuis 1975
et la loi Veil.
*-Je suis enceinte
et j'aimerais procéder
à une IVG médicamenteuse.
-En France,
une femme sur trois
a recours au moins une fois
dans sa vie à l'avortement.
220 000 interruptions
volontaires de grossesse
sont pratiquées chaque année.
Un droit
encore jugé et stigmatisé.
-J'ai eu un personnel soignant
qui m'a énormément culpabilisée,
en disant
que si mon copain
ne me forçait pas
à le garder,
c'est que forcément,
il m'aimait pas,
que je tuais un être vivent,
que j'étais odieuse.
-Les gens gardent
une idée négative
de la femme qui fait
une interruption de grossesse.
C'est surtout ça qu'il faut changer.
-Un droit
que ces opposants
aimeraient supprimer.
*-Pro-vie !
-Comme aux Etats-Unis
depuis qu'il n'est plus garanti
par la Cour suprême.
*-Notre but :
l'abolition de la loi Veil !
La foule l'acclame.
-Alors, l'idée est née en France
de le constitutionnaliser
pour mieux le protéger.
-Il faudrait inscrire
l'avortement comme un droit
qui ne se questionne pas,
quelque chose qui fait partie
de la santé des femmes.
-En novembre dernier,
l'Assemblée a adopté
à une large majorité l'inscription
du droit à l'avortement
dans la Constitution.
*-Chers collègues,
je suis très émue
à la fois de ce vote
et de ce signal historique
que l'Assemblée nationale
s'honore à envoyer
à toutes les femmes
de notre pays, mais aussi
à l'ensemble des femmes du monde.
-Première étape d'un long chemin
vers sa possible
constitutionnalisation.
Si sur le papier, le droit
à l'avortement semble acquis,
son accès est-il garanti
partout sur le territoire ?
Comment sont prises en charge
les femmes ?
L'IVG est-elle un acte médical
comme un autre ?
-DEBOUT FEMMES ESCLAVES
ET BRISONS NOS ENTRAVES
DEBOUT DEBOUT DEBOUT
Applaudissements
Un téléphone sonne.
-Le Planning familial,
bonjour.
*-J'ai un retard de règles,
en fait.
Et...
Et je pense que... Je pense que,
voilà, je suis enceinte.
Et j'aimerais procéder
à une IVG médicamenteuse.
-Vous avez combien de jours
de retard, aujourd'hui ?
*-Pour être franche, je devais
les avoir la semaine dernière.
Depuis, je les ai pas eues.
J'avais des douleurs, je pensais
que c'était les règles
mais au final, non.
-Pour une IVG
par aspiration,
ça sera directement vers l'hôpital
qu'il faudra se diriger,
vers les centres IVG
des hôpitaux.
*-Et ça se passe comment
si elle a pas d'assurance maladie ?
-Elle pourra se tourner
vers le service social
de l'hôpital,
qui prendra en charge
son avortement.
-Au Planning familial de Paris,
les conseillères conjugales
reçoivent les appels
et orientent les femmes
qui souhaitent mettre fin
à leur grossesse.
-Y a tous types d'âges
qui viennent au Planning familial
pour demander un avortement,
parce que les personnes savent
que ça va être un lieu bienveillant,
où elles vont pouvoir
se sentir bien,
être à l'écoute, non jugées,
un accueil non culpabilisant.
-Les femmes trouvent ici
une écoute.
A aucun moment
on ne leur demande
pourquoi elles font ce choix.
On ne juge pas
leur décision.
Jusqu'à sept semaines
de grossesse,
elles peuvent choisir la méthode
d'IVG médicamenteuse
ou instrumentale. Au Planning,
la médecin réalise
les IVG médicamenteuses,
une conseillère les accompagne.
-Vous, vous avez déjà fait
l'échographie de datation ?
-Non.
-D'accord.
Vous non plus ? Non.
Il y en a encore trois à passer.
Le groupe, et on discutera
réellement après,
ce sera après
l'échographie de datation.
-Après l'examen
avec le médecin,
les femmes sont reçues
en groupes.
C'est un temps d'échange
avant la mise en place
du protocole et la prise
des médicaments
qui entraîneront la fausse couche.
Ce jour-là,
elles n'ont pas accepté
la présence de notre caméra,
même anonymement.
S'il est autorisé
depuis près de 50 ans,
l'avortement reste tabou.
-La question n'est pas si simple
et assez taboue, oui.
Alors, il y a quelques milieux
où ça ne l'est plus,
mais en règle générale,
j'ai l'impression
que ça reste assez tabou,
on ne veut pas en parler.
Il y a encore une femme
qui est allée voir sa gynécologue,
la première réaction, c'est :
"Félicitations,
c'est une bonne nouvelle."
Alors que pour plein de femmes,
c'en est pas une.
-Et on culpabilise
encore les femmes
de ne pas se réjouir
d'une grossesse ?
-Ben, on n'arrête pas
de les culpabiliser.
"C'est de leur faute, elles auraient
pu faire attention...
"Maintenant,
avec la contraception,
"comment on fait
pour être enceinte ?"
-Une partie des femmes
qui viennent
au Planning familial sont envoyées
par leur généraliste
ou leur gynécologue.
Car tout médecin a le droit
de refuser de pratiquer l'IVG,
c'est la clause de conscience.
-Les gynécologues,
ils ne le disent pas,
qu'ils ont une clause de conscience.
C'est affiché nulle part.
Ils ne sont pas obligés
de le dire.
Mais on a énormément de femmes
qui viennent faire des avortements
ou qu'on a au téléphone
et qu'on oriente
parce qu'elles sont allées voir
leur gynécologue ou un gynécologue,
ou une gynécologue,
femme ou homme, c'est pareil,
qui leur a dit qu'il ne faisait pas
d'avortement.
C'est une manière détournée...
Ils ne disent pas qu'ils sont contre
mais ils ne font pas.
Là, cet après-midi,
la gynéco lui a dit
qu'elle était pas habilitée
à faire les IVG.
-3 % seulement des gynécologues
et des médecins en cabinet
pratiquent l'IVG.
Les femmes doivent alors
se tourner vers l'hôpital
ou le Planning familial.
Depuis 60 ans,
ici, on lutte pour le droit
à la contraception
et à l'avortement.
Et aujourd'hui,
pour sa constitutionnalisation.
Pour sa présidente,
un vrai danger plane sur l'IVG.
-Il y a toujours eu
des anti-choix, mais aujourd'hui,
ils ont gagné des batailles.
Aux Etats-Unis, ils ont gagné,
en Hongrie, ils ont gagné,
en Italie, ils vont gagner,
sûrement,
donc il faut être
hyper vigilantes,
pourquoi en France,
ce serait une exception ?
Il faut faire en sorte
que ce soit un droit fondamental,
essayer de le protéger un maximum,
en même temps, le rendre effectif,
parce que cette bataille-là
est toujours au quotidien
pour le Planning
et pour les associations féministes.
Il y a quelque chose à faire.
De constitutionnaliser l'avortement,
en France, on serait les premiers
et ça résonnerait
dans le monde entier.
*Musique dance
*-Pour la Marche
pour la vie,
est-ce que vous êtes chauds ?
-OUAIS !
*-On vous entend pas !
Est-ce que vous êtes chauds ?
-OUAIS !
-Portés par leurs victoires
aux Etats-Unis et en Hongrie,
les anti-avortement
donnent de la voix ce dimanche-là.
Depuis 2005, ces catholiques
conservateurs et traditionnalistes
organisent une manifestation
à Paris, la Marche pour la vie.
Ils défilent tous les ans
autour de l'anniversaire
de la loi Veil.
A leur tête, leur porte-parole,
Aliette Espieux.
Depuis deux ans,
elle a pris les rênes
de la manifestation.
*-Civilisation !
-Elle est plus que jamais
mobilisée
contre la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG.
-DEFENSEURS DE CIVILISATION !
-Ce qu'il y a de paradoxal
avec cette constitutionnalisation
de l'avortement,
et c'est ce qui, pour moi,
donne quelque chose de dramatique
et de vraiment pervers
de la part du gouvernement,
c'est que l'article 66-1
de la Constitution
interdit, abolit
la peine de mort.
Et l'article qui suivra
sera donc l'autorisation
de mettre à mort des enfants.
Et c'est là, l'énorme paradoxe,
c'est qu'on interdit la peine
de mort pour les criminels,
pour les violeurs,
pour les pédophiles,
et à côté de ça, on va dire
qu'un enfant, selon la situation,
selon le contexte dans lequel
il est attendu, on peut le tuer.
-Celle qui a rajeuni
et modernisé le mouvement
espère bien abolir
la loi Veil.
*-Pro-vie !
Moi, je souhaite envoyer
un deuxième signal au monde entier,
celui d'une France réveillée !
La foule l'acclame.
...
Une France héroïque,
prête à tout pour refermer
cette boîte de pandore
ouverte par Simone Veil.
Le public hue.
-La bataille se joue aussi
en coulisses.
Ces opposants à l'avortement
s'infiltrent jusqu'au Parlement.
Pendant les débats
sur la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG,
la députée Pascale Martin
portait la parole de son groupe
dans l'hémicycle.
Quelques jours avant les débats,
elle a reçu une lettre particulière.
-"L'avortement n'est pas un droit
mais un acte sanglant
"par lequel il est mis fin
à la vie d'un être humain
"tel que le foetus
de 12 semaines
"entre vos mains.
"Pensez-vous sincère que cet acte
soit un droit fondamental
"ayant sa place
dans la Constitution ?"
Donc, ils sont persuadés
qu'un foetus,
c'est un être humain
et qu'il a des droits d'être humain,
comme s'il était déjà en vie.
Ce type de courrier,
moi, ça m'a mis assez en colère.
Après, il y a
un sentiment de dégoût,
parce que ça joue
sur le visuel, évidemment.
Je connaissais pas cet organisme,
on s'est renseignés
et on a vu à qui on avait affaire.
-Cet organisme,
c'est le Centre européen
pour le droit et la justice,
une association
conservatrice chrétienne
très active
au Parlement européen.
-Il y a tout un lobbying
autour de ça
qui est vraiment insupportable,
mais ça veut aussi dire
qu'ils ont de l'argent
et que derrière,
des gens les financent.
Donc, c'est pour ça qu'il faut
vraiment être en résistance,
parce que ça peut tout à fait,
demain,
basculer vers quelque chose
que je ne souhaite pas
et que des millions de femmes
ne souhaitent pas.
-Pour faire interdire
l'avortement,
l'association
ne se contente pas
d'envoyer des lettres
aux parlementaires.
Ce jour-là,
avant l'examen
de la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG au Sénat,
elle est invitée par le sénateur
d'extrême droite
Stéphane Ravier.
Ancien cadre
du Rassemblement National,
passé depuis chez Eric Zemmour,
c'est un fervent opposant
à la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG.
-Pour aborder ce débat
sur la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG plutôt que de céder,
encore une fois,
aux passions, aux exigences
des individus,
des individualités,
j'ai souhaité que nous élevions
le débat.
Qu'il y ait un débat, déjà,
parce que c'est très difficile
d'avoir un débat sur ce sujet,
et que nous élevions le débat
avec des personnalités,
des professeurs qui sont,
je dirais,
dépollués de toute considération
partisane, justement.
-Pourtant, les quatre conférenciers
invités sont tous fermement opposés
à cette constitutionnalisation,
à l'image
de Grégor Puppinck,
président du Centre européen
pour le droit et la justice,
celui qui envoie des lettres
aux députés.
*-L'avortement,
on le voit bien, fait mal.
Ce n'est pas un concept
ni une liberté abstraite
mais une réalité dure.
L'avortement ne sera jamais
un véritable droit humain
mais seulement une violation
ou une dérogation
au droit au respect de la vie.
Nous sommes tous, ici,
des universitaires,
enseignants, docteurs,
nous écrivons des livres,
des articles scientifiques,
donc ce n'est pas du lobbying
que de donner une analyse juridique,
une analyse sociologique
sur ce sujet.
-Aucun sénateur n'a répondu
à l'invitation.
Deux jours plus tard,
le Sénat votait pour
la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG.
Musique légère
...
Loin du combat politique,
le droit à l'avortement
reste fragile sur le terrain,
victime des déserts médicaux
et des choix de santé publique.
En 2023,
l'accès à l'IVG est inégal.
En 20 ans,
130 maternités ont fermé
et avec elles,
la possibilité
pour les femmes d'avorter.
C'est l'histoire de Rethel,
dans les Ardennes.
Une ville de 8000 habitants
à 45 km de Reims.
En 2010, la maternité
ferme ses portes,
le centre périnatal
n'assure plus que les suivis
de grossesses.
Il faudra attendre 2016
et l'engagement du Dr Odile Maurice
pour que les femmes
aient à nouveau accès à l'IVG.
-C'est une population
qui est très rurale,
souvent...
..à un niveau socioéconomique,
bien sûr, bas,
avec des difficultés
de transport.
Souvent, c'est des patientes
qui n'ont pas de voiture
ou qui ne conduisent pas,
dont les maris, des fois,
ne sont pas véhiculés non plus.
Donc, l'avantage d'avoir
la consultation sur place,
c'est qu'elles peuvent être
un peu plus autonomes.
Et moi, j'ai vu, à l'époque
où c'était pas possible à Rethel,
ou même quand des fois,
je ne suis pas là,
des patientes garder leur grossesse
parce qu'elles ne pouvaient pas
venir jusqu'à Reims
faire leur interruption
de grossesse.
C'est important d'avoir
la possibilité,
d'avoir le choix ou pas
de garder une grossesse.
Je ne défends pas
l'IVG à tout prix
mais je défends le droit au choix
dans de bonnes conditions.
-Médecin au CHU de Reims,
Odile Maurice vient ici
tous les vendredis.
Elle assure les consultations
et prend en charge
les IVG chirurgicales
par aspiration
pour les femmes qui le souhaitent
et pour celles qui ont dépassé
les sept semaines de grossesse.
C'est alors
la seule méthode possible.
-21 ans.
Vous êtes en couple ?
-Oui.
-Ca fait combien de temps ?
-Ca fait deux ans.
-D'accord.
Ca se passe bien ?
-Oui.
-Il est gentil ?
-Pas de violences ?
-Non, du tout.
En fait, j'ai été chez mon médecin
d'abord, pour quelques symptômes,
et il m'a conseillé d'aller faire
une prise de sang.
J'ai eu les résultats
le soir même, du coup...
J'étais un peu stressée,
quand même !
C'est pas...
C'est pas anodin.
J'ai déjà eu assez de mal
pour avoir
un rendez-vous. De base,
j'avais déjà appelé Charleville,
qui ne pouvait pas
avant un certain temps.
-Combien de temps ?
-Charleville ?
-Mm.
-Pas avant deux semaines.
C'était quand même plus pratique
de savoir assez rapidement,
parce que j'étais déjà assez,
comment dire,
loin dans la grossesse,
donc voilà.
-Vous n'êtes pas loin
dans la grossesse,
d'accord ?
Franchement, vous êtes
dans les délais.
-Laura est à neuf semaines
de grossesse.
-Par rapport à l'âge
de la grossesse,
la méthode possible,
c'est la méthode instrumentale,
au bloc opératoire.
Vous avez lu sur la feuille ?
-Oui.
-Vous avez vu
comment ça se passait ?
Avec deux possibilités,
soit sous anesthésie générale,
où vous dormez complètement,
soit sous anesthésie locale,
où on endort juste la zone
où on passe les instruments.
C'est pas complètement
sans douleur,
vous allez ressentir
un certain nombre de choses.
-Nous retrouverons Laura
pour son opération
quelques jours plus tard.
Sans le médecin à Rethel,
son parcours aurait été
plus compliqué :
plus d'attente et de kilomètres
pour interrompre sa grossesse.
Pour proposer plus de consultations,
les sages-femmes de Rethel
se sont formées.
Depuis deux ans, elles prennent
en charge les IVG médicamenteuses,
une quarantaine chaque année.
Maud Cornu avait déjà suivi
Aurélie pour une grossesse,
elle l'accompagne aujourd'hui
pour son avortement.
-Bien. Comment ça va, aujourd'hui ?
-Ca va.
Dans mon cas, c'était voulu
et finalement, le projet s'arrête
et voilà, donc...
On a le droit de changer d'avis.
Et heureusement que ça existe
parce que sinon,
on serait avec un bébé.
-Vous trouvez qu'il y a toujours
un tabou autour de cette question ?
-Oui, je trouve.
Même en parler à la famille,
c'est compliqué.
-Vous avez pu en parler
autour de vous ?
-Moi, y a que mon mari
qui est au courant,
sinon personne d'autre.
Heureusement qu'on a
des professionnels pour se confier,
sinon c'est dur, en fait.
-Généralement, après la prise
de ce premier médicament,
la plupart du temps,
il ne se passe rien de particulier.
Il est très important de prendre,
24 à 48 heures après,
les deux autres, d'accord ?
Comme on est juste au-dessus
de sept semaines,
c'est deux comprimés.
Si jamais vous êtes inquiète,
ça a beau être noté,
on a beau l'avoir abordé,
mais si c'est pas clair,
que vous ne savez plus trop,
n'hésitez pas à appeler,
il y aura toujours quelqu'un
pour vous répondre.
OK ? D'accord.
-A Rethel, le délai
de prise en charge des femmes
est de cinq jours.
Ici comme partout en France,
l'accès à l'avortement
est avant tout
une histoire d'engagement
des professionnels.
Depuis un an, la loi permet
aux sages-femmes de pratiquer
les IVG chirurgicales.
C'est l'une des pistes pour garantir
l'accès à l'avortement,
mais pas encore effective
faute de décret d'application.
Maud, en tout cas,
est prête à s'y former.
-Si c'est une nouvelle compétence,
je m'en saisirai, c'est certain.
S'il n'y a pas le Dr Maurice
dans les années, on sait jamais,
ce sera une offre en moins.
Je ne vois pas,
à l'heure actuelle,
qui pourrait la remplacer
pour l'IVG chirurgicale.
Même si effectivement,
les trois quarts des IVG
qu'on réalise actuellement
sont des IVG médicamenteuses,
des fois, il y a besoin
de l'autre méthode.
Je pense que c'est important
parce que ça va clairement
permettre de réduire
les inégalités d'accès
sur le territoire,
c'est certain.
On est quand même 26 000
en France.
Musique douce
-Former et spécialiser les soignants
dans ce domaine,
c'est l'objectif
du diplôme universitaire
de régulation des naissances.
A Paris, Nathalie Trignol
enseigne et transmet son expérience
auprès de futurs médecins
et de sages-femmes.
-L'interruption volontaire
de grossesse,
c'est simplement
la situation d'une femme
qui est fertile,
qui a eu un rapport sexuel
et qui se trouve enceinte
à un moment
où c'est pas le moment pour elle.
Il y a une différence entre
la possibilité d'être enceinte
et le désir d'être mère.
Il y a plus de grossesses
qui surviennent de façon inopinée
que ce qu'on pense.
Et parmi ces grossesses inopinées,
il y en a un tiers
qui vont être interrompues.
-Ces élèves viennent approfondir
leurs connaissances
sur cet acte délaissé
de la médecine.
-C'est abordé dans nos études,
plus la contraception que l'IVG,
selon moi,
mais je trouve que c'est survolé,
ça nous donne pas les outils pour,
en pratique,
pouvoir répondre
de manière adaptée et complète
à la demande des patientes.
-Au-delà de la technique
médicale,
ils sont sensibilisés
à l'accueil des femmes.
C'est ce qui a poussé Calistine
à se former.
L'une des patientes qu'elle suit
a été traumatisée
par un psychologue.
-En fait,
elle lui avait demandé :
"J'ai peur de ce qui va sortir
de moi,
"qu'est-ce que je vais voir
après l'IVG ?"
Et il lui avait répondu :
"Vous verrez pas grand-chose,
vous allez perdre un petit oeuf,
"mais il y aura
deux points noirs
"et ce sera les yeux
de votre conscience."
Et en fait, cette patiente
n'a pas réalisé cette IVG
et là, elle revenait dans le cadre
d'une grossesse, du coup,
qu'elle ne souhaitait pas garder
parce que c'était un contexte
très compliqué avec son conjoint,
sa situation professionnelle,
qu'elle avait déjà quatre enfants,
et elle me disait : "Je ne peux pas
le garder, je ne veux pas,
"mais j'ai peur de ces deux
points noirs que je verrai."
Elle avait entendu ça
10 ans auparavant.
Et finalement, elle a gardé
cette grossesse, et voilà.
J'aurais aimé être là
il y a 10 ans
pour lui dire
que tout va bien se passer.
-Le regard des autres, le jugement,
ces professionnels
y sont eux-mêmes confrontés.
-On sent quand même,
de la part de certains collègues,
quelque chose de l'ordre de :
"Pourquoi tu fais ça ?"
Un peu, c'est pas du soin,
c'est pas considéré, parfois,
comme du soin,
comme intéressant
intellectuellement ou comme...
C'est : "Il faut bien qu'il y ait
des gens qui le fassent,
"tant mieux que toi,
tu t'en occupes."
C'est jamais dit
complètement frontalement.
-C'est pas valorisé.
-Pas du tout.
-Quand on s'intéresse
à la question
et qu'on est soignant,
qu'on est dans l'humain,
dans l'empathie
et qu'on veut aider les autres,
je comprends pas comment
on peut être soignant, humain,
faire de la médecine des femmes
et ne pas considérer
que l'avortement,
c'est la base.
On est ravis de voir que,
dans la jeune génération,
il y a une relève qui arrive
pour ce champ de la médecine.
Musique intense
-A Rethel,
nous retrouvons
au bloc opératoire Laura,
la patiente du Dr Maurice.
La jeune femme a choisi
l'anesthésie locale.
...
-Ca va, vous êtes
assez confortable ?
Je vais commencer l'anesthésie.
Voilà, voilà.
C'est super.
Aspiration
...
C'est fini. Ca va ?
-Elle est déçue,
elle pensait que ça serait pire !
-Je vous embête pas,
on va vous remettre correctement.
Du coup, la douleur,
entre 0 et 10,
c'était à combien,
au maximum ?
-Je dirais 4. En fait,
c'était plus désagréable.
-Oui.
-Je m'attendais vraiment à pire.
-Bon, ben tant mieux !
-L'intervention
a duré 15 minutes.
Depuis qu'elle est pratiquée
de manière légale,
l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse
est sans danger pour la santé
ou la fertilité des femmes.
-Ca va ?
Vous avez eu une petite collation,
ça y est ?
-Oui.
-La douleur, là,
c'est comment, maintenant ?
-Là, actuellement,
j'ai pas mal.
-Y a plus de douleur.
Vous avez vérifié les saignements ?
-Oui.
-Ca saigne normalement ?
-Ca va, oui.
-C'est une page qui se tourne
pour Laura,
un événement
dans sa vie de femme
auquel elle donnera
la place qu'elle souhaite.
-J'ai pas de honte à faire ça.
Je trouve que c'est mieux comme ça.
-Tant mieux.
-Voilà.
Je me sens rassurée
et soulagée, surtout.
Je m'attendais vraiment à pire
et en fait, ça a été, je trouve.
C'était surtout angoissant,
en fait,
parce que je savais pas
à quoi m'attendre.
Déjà, je vais mieux dormir.
J'arrivais plus du tout à dormir,
j'y pensais beaucoup,
donc c'était compliqué.
Ouais, je pense que ça ira mieux
dans à peu près tout !
Je vais reprendre
une vie normale !
-Un accueil bienveillant,
dans des délais raisonnables,
le choix de la méthode,
c'est ce que garantit
en théorie la loi.
Il reste encore des étapes
avant que le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
ne soit peut-être inscrit
dans la Constitution.
Il faudra soit un référendum,
soit que les députés
et les sénateurs
se réunissent en congrès
à Versailles.
Quelle qu'en soit l'issue,
les professionnels et les femmes
espèrent avant tout
un meilleur accès à l'IVG
partout en France.
Musique douce
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...